este partido lleva meses manifestándose
contra el referéndum constitucional y
contra los nuevos y amplios poderes de
caixa y en el que siempre se ha
posicionado en contra de la revolución
de 2011 es el liderado por javier mons y
conocida por sus posiciones extremas
anti islamistas en el parlamento
denuncia la falta de cambios desde que
el presidente asumió el poder
sabe que el pueblo tunecino ha dicho
tenemos hambre es nuestro país está en
bancarrota nuestras prioridades son
económicas sociales y financieras hoy
nadie puede invertir en túnez nadie
puede prestar a túnez nadie puede
desarrollarse mientras el gobierno no
sea legítima pero la oposición a cádiz
iedt es diversa el partido islamista
enhada y otros también se manifiestan
desde hace meses por separado
el mero hecho de organizar estas
manifestaciones demuestra que la
oposición está ganando terreno
sin embargo quienes se han movilizado
son principalmente partidarios y
desgarró al total de la población es hay
una confusión total entre la población y
entre los jóvenes con respecto a estas
estructuras y estas construcciones
políticas pero también hubo errores
cometidos por los propios dirigentes
políticos y por esta clase política
hoy los partidos están pagando un alto
precio por la falta de autocrítica solo
un partido importante el liberal afectó
un es y algunos partidos menores han
optado por hacer campaña por el 'no' en
el referéndum el clima
y
el clima se ha vuelto nocivo el clima se
ha vuelto muy violento hay un discurso
violento y este discurso viene
principalmente del jefe del estado
ese discurso suele ir dirigido contra la
clase política es una señal de que este
referéndum por una constitución con
poderes hiper presidenciales es visto
como un repudio a los que gobernaron
después de la revolución